I know you're already sleeping together
wait a second hold on hold on you're in
her mother's house you're talking about
buying a house but you're concerned
about buying a ring let's look at this
no no the wedding what I'm concerned
about is using a lot of money on the
wedding and all that you don't have to
use a lot of money on the wedding
Dominic please don't buy a house with
someone you're not married to really
I've been doing this 30 years and I've
heard unbelievable horror stories
because you now have a partner you have
no protection under the law this is
relationally backwards it's uh legally
dumb and it's financially stupid and
everybody thinks it's all okay because
if we're going to play house we ought to
have a house to play house listen dude
get married and then buy the house I
don't care if you have to put off buying
the house a little bit because you
bought too expensive a wedding I don't
care if you have an inexpensive wedding
and go buy the house anyway but do this
in the right order please